the global fight over chinese tennis
champion punxsui is intensifying this
morning the international olympic
committee says it confirmed pung is safe
and well in a second video call with the
player who disappeared for three weeks
after accusing a top chinese official of
sex abuse that's not good enough for the
women's pro tour and a growing
international course of tennis greats
elizabeth palmer is following the story
from seoul south korea elizabeth good
morning
morning yes the women's tennis
association has actually announced that
it's going to cancel all the very
lucrative tours it had planned to have
in china until the chinese government
addresses pong's allegations of sexual
assault
here's the last time we saw video of pun
released by chinese state media on
november 21st it was supposed to prove
she wasn't being punished for her social
media post that accused 75 year old
former vice premier zhang gaoli of
coercing her into sex but it didn't
convince the women's tennis association
in a statement ceo steve simon said
while we now know where pong is i have
serious doubts that she is free safe and
not subject to censorship and
intimidation
peng shui three-time olympian is a mega
star in china which has a huge and
growing appetite for tennis but the
women's tennis association says it has
cancelled all upcoming tournaments there
a move that will cost it hundreds of
millions of dollars until the chinese
government looks into pung's assault
allegations the biggest stars in tennis
from naomi osaka and serena williams to
novak djokovic are firmly on the wta's
side i support fully
wta's stance because
we don't have
enough information about shaipeng and
her well-being
but the ioc which published a picture of
its president on a video call with pong
is pursuing what it's calling quiet
diplomacy to deal with the situation
that would probably suit the chinese
government just fine it's putting
finishing touches on sports facilities
to stage the winter olympics in beijing
in february critics say it just wants
this scandal to go away but the ioc
shouldn't let that happen the olympics
is very important to china
the ioc could use that as leverage to
facilitate an actual investigation over
allegations it's chosen not to
it should
now the chinese government has not
addressed these allegations directly and
as for the sponsors conspicuous silence
there too they are between the rock of
this chinese metoo moment and the hard
place of big booming profits in the
chinese market nate oh vlad
we'll all take it all right we look
alike yeah we're all gonna take it and
first of all liz we also want to wish
you congratulations you are reporting
from seoul south korea you are our new
asia correspondent you've reported from
all over the world um you were one of
the first correspondents into
afghanistan after 9 11.
we're so happy we're so proud of you liz
my girl
so happy for you
congratulations
please sure thank you
love you bye love you back so this is an
important story as liz points out one of
the things that's interesting is how
women are severely underrepresented
within chinese politics and so this is a
real problem for the communist party in
china yeah and i commend the wta you
know for standing on what they believe
and investigating doing their due
diligence you know because oftentimes
silence can be complying with what is
going on and they're saying no we need
more answers yeah and it feels as if
sorry michelle i was going to say it
feels as if the chinese government is
starting to see big names coming out and
talking about this that creates problems
for them i'm glad she didn't stay silent
that's right all right up